[Music]
people say
you you have to have a lot of passion
for what you're doing and it's totally
true
and the reason is uh is because it's so
hard that if you don't any rational
person would give up
it's really hard and you have to do it
over a sustained period of time
so if you don't love it if you're not
having fun doing it you don't really
love it
uh you're gonna give up and that's what
happens to most people actually if you
really look at
at the ones that uh ended up you know
being successful unquote in the eyes of
society and the ones that didn't
oftentimes it's the ones that are
successful loved what they did so they
could persevere
when you know when it got really tough
and and the ones that
didn't love it quit because they're sane
right who would want to put up with this
stuff if you don't love it so it's a lot
of hard work
and and it's a lot of worrying
constantly and
if you don't love it you're going to
fail so you got to love it you got to
have passion
the key point there is you've got to
enjoy what you do every day
and for me that's working with very
smart people
it's working on new problems you know
every time we think
hey we've had a little bit of success
we're pretty careful not to dwell on it
too much because
the bar gets raised
[Music]
i would love to discuss something about
the failures mistakes we made
the thing i feel most thankful is all
the mistakes
of the reviews that i got because
without that
it would never be alibaba in the past
18 years every day we make mistakes
every day we were rejected i think being
rejected
being refused by people that is very
natural
why people should help you you have to
prove
yourself then people would help you
today
there are a lot of books about us i
don't read these books because i think
this book's not about
us people love to see successful stories
but most of the success stories they
succeed
because of the mistakes i encourage all
the young people entrepreneurs
to learn from the mistakes do not study
successful studies
successful successful stories in the
harvard business school
normally you know there are a lot of
things behind you don't know
but if you learn from the mistakes if
you learn
especially the failures casey studies
it's going to help you
what i want to say is not about you you
learn from mistakes does not mean you
will
avoid mistakes you will learn the
attitude
towards these mistakes and never give up
fighting again
[Music]
i would follow my passion i mean
whatever turned you on
you know i uh i found i was lucky i
found something early that
that turned me on but but uh
you don't want to take a job just for
the money you don't want to take a job
for an organization that you really
don't feel good about or work for people
that you don't feel good about you
you really want to be excited when you
get out of bed every morning and it
won't necessarily be the job that you
have 10 years later
but you'll be learning so much as you go
along
[Music]
just work like hell i mean you just have
to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour weeks
every week
i mean if if other people are putting in
40 hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve
you will achieve in four months what it
takes them
a year to achieve
learned enough to be dangerous and this
is like one of the lessons in
entrepreneurship
is that like you don't have to be the
best but you have to be dangerous
right you have to learn just enough to
be dangerous to build an idea
concept it and show it to the world and
then it turns out there are lots of
other people including all 170 employees
that work at instagram who are much
better at doing all that stuff than i am
but you need to find people who can you
know be drawn to the idea that you build
and and then they end up taking it and
um and making it even better
[Music]
the secret sauce of amazon where there
are several principles at amazon but the
number one thing
that has made us successful by far is
obsessive compulsive
focus on the customer as opposed to
obsession over the competitor and i talk
so often
to other ceos and
some other ceos and also founders and
entrepreneurs
and i can tell that even though they're
talking about customers
they're really focusing on competitors
and it is a huge advantage
to any company if you can stay focused
on your customer instead of your
competitors
[Music]
to me entrepreneurship is about creating
change not just creating companies
and you know the most effective
entrepreneurs that who i've met
care deeply about some mission and some
change that they're trying to create
and often they don't even start because
they're trying to create a company
right and you know that's how i think
about um
you know my connection to to all of us
here is
you know i was getting started i um you
know i wanted i care deeply about giving
everyone
uh a voice right and giving people the
tools to share everything that they
cared about and
uh bringing a community together and you
know it started small and in one
university
and i didn't think it was going to be a
company at the time as a matter of fact
i was pretty convinced that at some
point someone would build
something like this for the world but uh
you know i thought that would be some
other company that you know already had
thousands of engineers and
was used to building stuff for hundreds
of millions of people around the world
and
you know what ended up happening was um
you know that no one built it right so
we just kind of kept on going right i
mean
people said it each step along the way
um
you know what you're doing all right
maybe college students like it but no
one else is going to like it and
you know there's not gonna be any money
in doing this so all right so you only
really do it if you care
right if you're passionate about doing
it and then it started growing and
people said it would be a fad
and it would never be a good business
but you know you keep going because you
care
not because you're trying to create a
business um
and you know then there's the shift to
mobile where people thought
that it wouldn't be a sustainable
business and
um you know through each of these things
you the
the entrepreneurs who i think build
things that last for a long time
keep going because they care
fundamentally about the change that
they're trying to create in the world
um and they're not in it just to build a
company
and you know i carry that with me today
[Music]
you